let's bring in marwan bashara he's our
chief political analyst he joins us on
skype
from doha welcome back to the newshour
marwan at one point mr pence said
we've won the trade war against china
factually and financially that's not
actually true
not a hundred percent true for sure so
why
is a vp candidate the sitting vice
president
why is he kind of indulging in in half
truths at a time of such crucial change
and why is he viewing it as
an inaccurate interpretation of foreign
policy through the prism of trade policy
well look the question of china is is
probably the most important foreign
policy
challenge for the united states not just
for the trump administration
for any administration moving forward
that's why a roadmap a vision a strategy
of how to deal with china
is probably the most indispensable
issue facing any administration moving
forward
because as we all know from history from
1870 to today there is nothing more
destabilizing to the international
system than a global power competing
with a rising
world power and now china a rising world
power
wants to be an asian power to be an
asian power
it's probably going to have to confront
the united states in the asia pacific
that is a huge issue to be reduced
to a simple question of trade surplus
really is a huge disservice
to anyone who understands american
interest and american standing in the
world and yet
it was reduced to a question of trade
under the trump administration
and clearly as kamala harris has
demonstrated with figures that a lot of
farmers and other
blue labor uh americans have lost their
jobs i lost their livelihoods
because of this random confrontational
uh trump uh approached china not really
realizing
that china is not some medium-sized
country
with no ambition that china is
there head-to-head with the united
states they also clash directly over
this
specific issue marwan take a listen
the vice president earlier referred to
as part of
what he thinks is an accomplishment um
the the president's
trade war with china you lost that trade
war
you lost it what ended up happening
is because of a so-called trade war with
china
america lost 300 000 manufacturing jobs
farmers have experienced bankruptcy
because of it we are in a manufacturing
recession
because of it why is it marwan right now
over the past week or so we're also
hearing those republican voices those
gop supporter voices who may not
actually
like or support donald trump they're
kind of saying
mr trump isn't foreign policy but mr
trump is
foreign policy because he has personally
reset so many points of engagement
around the world be it china
the middle east his attitude towards
countries in africa his attitude towards
his personal interpersonal working
relationship with nato leaders as well
he has changed those a lot
this is one of the shortcomings of a
businessman
a ceo if you will come statesman
president trump uh has been boasting for
decades now about his capacity to
negotiate he even wrote books of course
helped by others
about how to negotiate the whole bit for
him is that i can sit with
president xi of china and i can convince
him of various things
of course the chinese don't work that
way they are statesmen
they are probably the longest duration
empire in the history of humankind
they understand systems and they
understand how to work
in terms of a huge bureaucracy so the
idea that president trump could simply
convince
president xi was of course a non-starter
not only that there's something even
more important personal relations don't
work
in such huge competitions as i was
saying between a rising power and a
global power
president obama did a number of things
they're not perfect they're not complete
they're not enough
but he did work out a number of trade
free trade agreements with a number of
countries
surrounding china he did pivot
to asia in the sense of sending more
navy power
to the asia pacific and he engaged china
on a number of issues including human
rights
chinese responsibility around the world
trade and so on so forth
this this was a system or as pamela
harris pulled it there was
a systematic approach of relations
with china and uh with america's allies
on the question of china
trump on the other hand engaged china on
trade
alienated the europeans who are there
america's most important ally for
any strategy moving forward with china
alienated
america's asian allies including vietnam
thailand japan south korea and others
that america
badly needs in order to contain china
economically so what we ended up with
president trump was wanting to cancel
everything obama
keeping up only with some random
personal uh relationship with chi
calling him best friend
this is another thing and of course it
all fall apart and now
america doesn't have much with which
to confront face compete or contain
china
okay uh final point marwan please why is
it
as we get closer to the election
november the third
this white house seems to want to live
in
an alternate reality be it kobit 19
donald trump putting out that video last
thing last night on twitter where he
just
looked and sounded peculiar but whether
it's
kovid 19 in america whether it's black
lives matter
whether it's relationships between
different countries across this region
in the middle east that spun as being
something
completely different to what it actually
is when the uae
and bahrain normalize relations with
israel that spun us peace in our time so
trump wants to live
in this parallel pocket universe of
something else
well the truth of the matter is and it's
regrettable
is that this alternate world did work
for trump for some three years
from 2016 when he first entered the
presidential elections and through
uh last year it worked for him the whole
you know hoopla circus entertainment
politics as entertainment personal
relationships
every day either allegedly lying about
something or the other deceiving in one
way or another
it tends to work for him and he actually
was for some
point of time relatively popular
certainly among his base
however something happened earlier in
the year
and that's the pandemic you just cannot
simply lie your way through the pendant
either you are ready
either you can manage it you can work
with a bureaucracy
you can work with science you can work
with the scientific community
you know how to calm the panic
and project confidence that's not just
personal
about your next election but also
in terms of implementing those sober
policies
uh among the americans whether it is
testing this and that developing
unfortunately the the pandemic test
for this administration was a major
fiasco
and since then certainly since march to
my mind
the circus no longer worked the
entertainment no longer worked the
deception no longer worked and hence
and that's what i called it recently in
one of the pieces while jazeera
is that i think and here it has two
meanings if you will
the trump administration has lost it
lost it in the sense it lost its mojo
if you will but also lost it in terms of
commanding a popular support for
four more years it's mojo contracted
coronavirus i think marwan marwan good
to talk to you as
ever a pleasure stay in touch we'll talk
to you soon